there are plenty of shocking finales in
Hollywood history but it takes a special
kind of climax to make someone leave the
theater in a fit of rage these movie
endings all sparked major controversies
sometimes for the silliest of reasons
major spoilers ahead when 10 Cloverfield
Lane arrived in 2016
people wondered if this sci-fi flick
would have any connection to the JJ
Abrams produced monster movie
Cloverfield that come out eight years
before was it a sequel or a prequel did
it take place in the same universe
whether being the aliens as moviegoers
quickly found out there were most
definitely aliens but not everyone was
happy when the evil et's showed up on
screen come on the space worms first
appear after our hero Michelle escapes
from an underground bunker for most of
the movie she's been held captive by
Howard a murderous conspiracy theorist
who thinks aliens have taken over the
world and when Michelle finally makes
her way to the surface she discovers
Howard was right seconds after defeating
her warden
Michelle is forced to fight against
invaders from another galaxy
this fiery finale ticked off quite a few
moviegoers as many thought the climax
was overblown and out of place
some said the movie self-destructed in
the last few minutes while others argued
Michelle didn't need to fight any
extraterrestrials as she'd already
beaten Howard on the other hand other
critics say the scene is essential for
Michelle's character arc now that she's
seen the alien foe up-close her decision
to join the resistance has real meaning
she now knows from first-hand experience
what dangers lie ahead so when she
drives toward the invasion we understand
she's finally overcome her fear and she
won't run away this time but regardless
of your opinion on the ending can we all
agree that John Goodman was way scarier
than any alien I'm sorry I accept your
apology directed by Nicholas Meyer Star
Trek 2 the Wrath of Khan features one of
the saddest death scenes you'll ever see
in a sci-fi movie after going toe-to-toe
with Khan the crew of the USS Enterprise
is in serious trouble
there is a superweapon about to go off
and Captain Kirk can't escape the blast
in time because the ship's warp drive
has been seriously damaged and that's
when Spock decides to save the day
putting the needs of the many ahead of
the needs of the few Spock exposes
himself to deadly radiation in hopes of
repairing the ship
no human can tolerate the radiation
that's in there as you are so fond of
observing doctor I am NOT human
while his plan works out and the
enterprise escapes intact our
pointy-eared hero dies a tragic death
separated from Kirk by a pane of glass
it's a heartbreaking scene and if you're
not getting a bit misty-eyed right now
it's probably because you're a Vulcan I
do not understand the question of course
fans back in 1982 weren't just upset
about Spock's demise they were downright
furious news of Spock's death leaked
pretty early during the filming of Wrath
of Khan resulting in a major outcry from
fans according to executive director
Harv Bennett the filmmakers received a
hundred thousand letters pleading for
Spock's life one Trek he took out a
Magus
demanding the Paramount's pair the
vulcan and some fans were so upset that
they started harassing actor Leonard
Nimoy actually threatening the man and
his family hoping to throw fans off
Meyer and the company added a scene
early in the film in which Spock fakes
his death during a training sequence and
honestly that probably only made it hurt
even more when the Vulcan finally gave
his trademark salute for the final time
well until Star Trek 3 the search for
Spock came out anyway when the devil
inside hit theaters in 2012 there were
multiple reports that audience members
began cheering and shouting an anger
after the credits started rolling so
what kind of ending would cause
moviegoers to unleash their inner demons
well the devil inside is a found footage
film about a killer named Maria who's
possessed by four demons her daughter
Isabella is making a documentary about
her murderous mom and eventually the
film culminates with an exorcism where
the demons decide to leave their host
and inhabit our heroes as a result
things take an unfortunate turn as
Isabella and her friend are speeding
down a busy highway suddenly her
possessed buddy turns into oncoming
traffic and the movie cuts to black
and that's when a title card pops up
reading the facts surrounding the Rossi
case remained unresolved for more
information about the ongoing
investigation visit www.kcc.hawaii.edu
that comes straight out of The Sixth
Sense supposedly said in the real world
you know a place where ghosts don't
exist
this 2013 romance focuses on a battered
wife named Katie she's on the run after
stabbing her husband and she eventually
winds up in a new town where she
befriends a local woman named Jo falls
in love with a hunky widower named Alex
as you probably guessed Katie and Alex
wind up together but moments before the
credits roll the couple discovers a
stack of letters written by Alex's dead
wife Carly they also find a photo of his
old flame and surprise she looks exactly
like Jo yeah that's right Katie sprint
Jo is the ghost of Alex's wife returned
from the afterlife to play matchmaker
for her hubby as twists go this one is
completely nuts especially considering
there weren't any apparent supernatural
elements in the movie until the end
in fact the finale was so bonkers that
one critic wrote that the twists will
make you want to punch the movie in the
face
directed by Seth Rogen and Evan Goldberg
the interview follows a talk-show host
and his producer as they visit North
Korea to well interview Kim jong-un but
before they reach Asia they're recruited
by the CIA to assassinate the dictator
initially reluctant they finally do the
deed when Kim decides to launch his
nuclear weapons as Kim sits in a
helicopter James Franco and Seth Rogen
blast him to kingdom come with a tank
and we watch in slow-mo as the bad guys
face catches on fire originally Kim's
death was way more violent his entire
head exploded sending chunks of skull
everywhere this did not set well with
the CEO of Sony who insisted that Rogen
toned down the gore but that was just
the start of what would become an
international incident the madness
really began when North Korea stated
that releasing the interview would be an
act of war things only got worse when a
North Korean backed group called the
guardians of peace hacked Sony began
releasing private emails and demanded
the studio shut down the controversial
comedy
and this is when things got kind of
scary the guardians of peace followed up
there hacking attack with terrorist
threats as a result five major theater
chains decided to drop the interview and
Sony initially declined to release the
movie online sure the movie eventually
did make its way into theaters and
streaming services but it's kind of
weird to think that decades from now
film students will still be talking
about how a ridiculous Seth Rogen movie
sparked an international incident though
do the right thing came out nearly 30
years ago it's just as relevant today as
it was in 1989 set during a vicious
summer heat wave in New York City this
spike Lee joint focuses on a small
neighborhood divided by race the film
takes place over the course of a single
day and we watch as an argument between
the pizza shop owner and two customers
escalates into a violent showdown the
madness starts with an NYPD officer
kills a young african-american man in
response the main character starts a
riot that destroys the affer mentioned
pizza parlor
[Applause]
it's a devastating climax one that
leaves audiences shaken to the core but
empathetic toward all the characters and
where they're coming from well that was
what was supposed to happen anyway
unfortunately a lot of people
misunderstood the movie and worried do
the right thing would incite real-life
riots one reviewer at the time wrote the
end of this movie is a shambles and if
some audiences go wild Lee is partly
responsible other critics apparently
felt the same way with one going so far
as to say the movie could have political
ramifications naturally this didn't set
well with Lee who told Rolling Stone I
don't remember people saying people were
going to come out of theaters killing
people after they watched Arnold
Schwarzenegger films
[Music]